Irish and Celtic mythology are things
that I've not really covered in much
detail so far they're definitely not
what you would consider mainstream in
comparison to Greek Egyptian or even
Norse mythology and any information
regarding them is much harder to come by
but this in no way means that they're
any less interesting than the others we
continue our journey today by taking a
look at quite a predominant figure the
goddess known as the Morrigan or
sometimes just Morrigan she was often
associated of war and the fate of those
that took part meaning that life and
death were considered to be her domain
the appearance of the Morricone before
battle was considered a bad omen some
believe that if a warrior was to see her
washing his armor it was a sign that he
would not return this in turn fueled the
belief that the choice of who walked
away from battle and who did not was
down to the Morrigan it became common
practice to leave the borders of the
Dead on the battlefield for a day
allowing time for Morgans crows to
collect them very similar to what we see
with Odin and his Ravens in Norse
mythology the Morgans association with
the life cycle grew over time and she
began to be seen as part of a trio of
sisters referred to as the Marigny
the trio consisted of the college is
known as Babs maca and the main Morgan
herself was thought to be a
shape-shifter taking a form of a raven
or a crow the two animals that she was
most often seen being accompanied by in
the stories of the Ulster cycle she was
also said to take the form of numerous
other animals including a cow an eel and
a wolf the Morgans origin is something
that has been passionately debated for
years and a mistake that most people
make is to assume that Celtic mythology
and Irish mythology are the same thing
Irish mythology is much older and the
more are going to paid there before she
did in Celtic mythology there's no doubt
that the two are closely linked with
aspects of traditional Irish mythology
bleedin into Celtic mythology and
helping shape its ideas there are only a
few mentions of the Morgan and Irish
mythology and that time she wasn't even
considered a goddess
but in the years to come she appeared in
Celtic mythology and that soon changed
her name in Celtic can be translated to
mean great queen of phantom Queen and in
Irish mythology she was considered to be
one of the leaders of the Dani tribe the
two added annan or a tribe of
supernatural beings in Irish mythology
that descended from the goddess Danny
herself one of the oldest deities in
Irish mythology they were thought to
have invaded Ireland in 1897 BC and
ruled for several hundreds of years the
Morgan was thought to help the people of
DeLong often shroud in the land in thick
layers of fog making it difficult to be
seen by opposing armies and invaders the
to a Danann were led by the Dagda and
there are many stories that allude to
the Morrigan and the Dagda having a
sexual relationship the doctor would
consider the goal of fertility and he
would meet with Morgan once a year and
together they would create new life
there is a portion of text in the calf
made torrid which accounts the first
battle between the two a Danann and
therefore mauryans
another supernatural race in Irish
mythology who often seen as extremely
hostile and monstrous beings who came
from the sea to raid the shores of
Ireland before the battle occurred the
Dagda know Morgan met so they could plan
which strategy they could implement now
many saw this meeting between the two as
the dag that almost traded sex for
victory but there are quite a few ways
we can interpret this story that would
suggest that otherwise the relationship
between the two had existed for some
time and with Morgan being part of the
two @nn she had already offered her
assistance on several different
occasions so it doesn't make much sense
that on this occasion she would demand
payment for her help before she met with
the Dagda Morgan had already visited Lou
one of the fiercest warriors within the
two @nn and she had chanted a battle
incitement that would bolster him and
rally his men we can see here that
Morgan is clearly in favor of the battle
and has already taken steps to help her
people there are many who saw Morgan as
a goddess of sexual desires but this
story allows us to interpret her in a
very different way if anything it is the
Dagda who is the god of sex as he's
closely associated fertility and it's
very clear that regardless of what the
two did during their meeting the Morgan
had every intention in helping him I
mentioned earlier that some people
believed that the two would come
together once a year and my
interpretation of these events is that
the
who met as they normally would but this
time it was a meeting of War and Morgan
shared her strategic knowledge of the
Dagda so she could help ensure that her
people were victorious in battle the
Morgan's lineage much like a lot of
Irish and Celtic mythology can vary as
there are very few written accounts that
we can go by the medieval Irish book
labore kabbalah ln the book of the takin
of ireland as we now refer to it
mentions that the irish mother goddess
ernest was the mother of morgan as well
as a trio of sister she was associated
with despite their annual meetings there
is no real mention of the Dagda and the
Morgan ever having a child the one piece
of hazy information we have suggest that
they may have had a child by the name of
Adair de Morgan's appearance and
artistic representations remain quite
similar despite how much we actually
know she was often seen as a beautiful
young woman with long flowing dark hair
with her being so heavily associated
with death her clothing was often black
she was known to take the form of a crow
or a raven both of them being carrion
birds and once again tying in to her
association with death it's likely that
the Morgan would have been seen as
strikingly beautiful to the Irish and
Celtic people but she would have also
painted an extremely intimidating figure
as seen the goddess was considered a bad
omen it's fairly difficult to draw too
many conclusions or even to summarize
the Morgan because of the lack of
knowledge and ambiguity that surrounds
her we know that she's an extremely
ancient deity that first appeared in
Irish mythology and then later became an
iconic figure in Celtic mythology she's
often described as quite a vengeful
deity one that would not hesitate to
take the life of someone who has wronged
her we do somewhat see this in the
Ulster cycle when the heroku colon
rejects the Morgans romantic approaches
she swears revenge upon him and
eventually appears to him washing his
armor and delivering him the omen of
death it's likely that the Irish and
Celtic people considered her to be an
extremely intelligent and fierce
individual when I first heard of the
Morgan I instantly thought of the
character from the first Dragon Age game
with the same name the to do somewhat
have similar personalities and her
appearance does resemble what I somewhat
described earlier the character was also
capable of shape-shifting and I'd like
to think that she was influenced by
either Irish or Celtic mythology
there are so many different
interpretations of the Morrigan that I
love to see how you see her do you
consider her a part of a trio of
goddesses similar to how we see a karta
in Greek mythology or do you see her as
a single entity were you familiar with
the tribal supernatural beings that she
belonged to or would you like me to
cover more of the supernatural beings
that appeared in Irish mythology let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained